now you can get a lot of great
information nutritionally with just
looking at someone's lips so today we're
going to talk about how to use the lips
to help diagnose what's going on inside
so let's start off with um just pale or
gray lips this is usually a situation
where you are anemic okay
now there's two main types of anemia one
would be an iron deficiency anemia and
the other one would be a b12 deficiency
anemia so it could be either or
but if you're deficient in copper
that could affect your ability to absorb
iron and so that can cause the
deficiency as well so it could be a lack
of copper iron or b12 now normally you
get iron in red meat and especially
liver and seafood
spinach is not a good source of iron
despite all those popeye cartoons so as
far as the scenarios that you could be
iron deficient
it could be you just don't consume
any meats at all you you're more of a
vegan it could also be a lack of
hydrochloric acid let's say for example
you're on an antacid
that can create a deficiency of iron or
let's say you're
consuming a lot of
grains with these phytates phytates are
like anti-nutrients they will block the
ability to absorb minerals especially
iron so if you're doing a lot of grains
that could be why you're iron deficient
now it could also be that you're a
female and you have heavy periods and
you're losing a lot of blood that's
another reason why you're anemic and
also it could be that you have
inflammation in your gut let's say you
have
ibs or some type of
crohn's or
diverticulitis or any type of
inflammatory problem with the bowels
that can definitely stop you from
absorbing
minerals including b12 now as far as the
anemia with b12 that can also be a lack
of hydrochloric acid it could also mean
that you're not consuming enough animal
products because that's where you get
b12 from animal products and so the same
things that can create an iron
deficiency could also create a b12
deficiency
all right what about if you have blue
lips okay well it could be that you just
came out of the cold
that could be one reason because
temperature can drive all the blood
internally and create a lack of blood
flow to your lips but it can also be
other things like you're in shock
it could also be a cyanide poisoning and
just as a side note there's a natural
remedy for cyanide poisoning i want to
bring your attention to it's called
hydroxyl cobolamine it's a type of b12
that you can actually order online
b12 combines with cyanide to form
cyanocobolamine and helping reduce that
toxicity now what about if your lips are
becoming darker
that could be your smoker or exposed to
a lot of secondhand smoke so of course
smoking has a lot of chemicals smoking
decreases oxygen and circulation in the
body but smoking will interfere with the
pigment melanin too and create a darker
appearance on your lips you'll you may
also notice these vertical wrinkles
around the mouth if you're a smoker all
right now what about dry lips
well there could be a couple different
reasons for dry lips the biggest one
would be a lack of essential fatty acids
uh specifically omega-3 fatty acids and
that could be either you're not
consuming enough omega-3 because you
don't eat fish or cod oil or it could be
more commonly a situation where you're
consuming a lot of omega-6 fatty acids
that would be in the typical foods
that you would eat at a fast food
restaurant or even a lot of the other
restaurants out there it's omega-6 fatty
acids that include corn oil soy oil
canola cottonseed oil which is in so
many of our foods
so a lot of people are heavy on that and
they're not doing enough omega-3 and
that will just totally dry out in your
lips which can also cause you to have
chapped lips so
dry lips and chapped lips kind of cross
over but if you have just generally dry
lips i would start to beef up your
omega-3 fatty acids with cod liver oil
or consuming more salmon things like
that wild caught salmon now if you have
chapped lips that could be a combination
of omega-3 fatty acid deficiency it
could also be a vitamin d deficiency
which you'll see in the winter time
and so this is why people have chapped
lips during the winter and they use
carmex or they might use different types
of lip balms but that usually dries out
the lips because it has a mineral oil
make sure you never put anything on your
body that has mineral oil because it can
extract the fat soluble vitamins that
includes taking mineral oil in any of
your products because that'll
extract the fat-soluble vitamins and end
up drying out things externally and
internally it's not good for the liver
it could also be a zinc deficiency or it
could be that you're getting too much
vitamin a so vitamin a toxicity
which would usually come from
a supplement you're taking with just
high doses maybe you're trying to get
rid of your acne and taking a lot of
vitamin a
and that is creating the vitamin a
toxicity which then will lead to um
chapped lips so any one of these
imbalances can create that when you have
too much vitamin a you can it can
actually deplete your vitamin d
um so it's really the balance of these
fat cyber vitamins and of course the
best way to get vitamin d is for the sun
okay so the sun will give you a good
amount of vitamin d um i have a lot of
videos on vitamin d i will put some
links down below now of course zinc you
would get in red meat okay you would
also get in seafood shellfish oysters
things like that now what about the
cracks in the corner of the mouth
that is usually a b2 deficiency that
usually occurs because you're consuming
too many refined carbohydrates okay
refined carbohydrates will create a b2
deficiency and it can show up as a crack
corner of the mouth the other way that
people become deficient and the other b
vitamins is they're lacking the
microbiome they usually had an
antibiotic or they're eating foods that
don't support the microbiome because
your microbiome can make b2 and the best
diet to give you b2 would be
a good amount of eggs egg yolk uh also
cheese make sure it's high quality
cheese not
american cheese
and the leafy greens will give you a
good amount of b2 and of course you're
gonna have to avoid the refined grains
so i just wanted to do this quick video
to kind of help you diagnose the inside
of your body just by looking at your
lips now i have a lot of other videos
to help diagnose internal deficiencies
by looking at a certain external parts
of the body including the nails so that
would be a good video for you to check
out i put it right here
you